[MUSIC PLAYING]
TAMMY STERN: Mitchel
Resnick is a Professor
of Learning Research at the MIT
Media Lab, where he develops
new technologies and
activities to engage
people, especially children, in
creative learning experiences.
His research team, called the
Lifelong Kindergarten Group,
develops the Scratch programming
software and online community,
the world's largest
coding platform for kids.
His group also collaborates
with the LEGO company
on the development of
new educational ideas
and products, including LEGO
MINDSTORMS robotics kits.
Mitchel co-founded the
Computer Clubhouse Project,
an international network of
100 after school centers,
where youth from low
income communities
learn to express
themselves creatively
with new technologies.
Mitchel and the
Scratch team have
partnered with
Google and Google.org
to increase youth coding efforts
through projects like CS First,
Google's CS curriculum
for nine to 14-year-olds,
and Blockly, which makes the
app development more accessible.
On a personal note, I worked
with Mitchel to develop Scratch
and traveled around the
world doing Scratch workshops
with children and educators.
I remember how exciting it was
for kids to build projects,
bringing their
creations to life,
and how enabling and
empowering these tools
can be for those who
might not otherwise
have found themselves coding.
Working with Mitchel
and the Scratch team
helped me internalize
that coding did not
need to be an exclusive skill
restricted to engineers,
but rather a tool to
enable anyone to creatively
express themselves, or to tackle
personally meaningful projects.
Mitchel's passion for people,
education, and empowerment
has inspired me and
countless others,
and I'm excited to introduce
him to speak with you all today.
[APPLAUSE]
MITCHEL RESNICK: OK, well,
thanks so much, Tammy.
It's great to be talking here
at Google, because as Scratch
continues to grow,
we're forming stronger
and stronger
collaboration with Google,
as I'll be mentioning
in the talk.
So it's great to be here
and to talk with you
and to share some of the work
we're doing now, and looking
ahead to some of the things
we're starting to work on,
many are projects
in collaboration
with people here at Google.
We've had lots of
different ways.
We've also been
very fortunate to be
able to have people from Google
who then come and work with us.
I'm here with my colleague,
Champika Fernando,
who we stole from Google twice.
She came to work with us and was
a student, went back to Google,
and then recently came back
and started working with us.
So there's been lots
of flow back and forth
of both people and ideas.
And it's been great to have
the history with Tammy.
So I even went back
into the archives
and found from when Scratch was
launched in 2007, 10 years ago,
this was the Scratch team.
And you can see myself
there, and there's
Tammy as an MIT--
she was finishing up
at MIT at the time.
I think shortly after this,
then started at Google.
So it's great to
reconnect and be
able to have continued through
the years to share ideas.
Since Tammy left the
Scratch team in 2007,
Scratch has continued
to grow and grow.
Like, you know, over
the last decade,
Scratch has really
grown, to where
there's a number
of people joining
the Scratch online community.
So this past year, there
were 8 million young people
who registered on the
Scratch online community.
And you can just see it's
been growing and growing
over the years.
But I think, for us, what's
most important is not
just the number of
people involved,
but the creativity
expressed by them,
and the way this is really
transforming their lives
and the way that they can create
things and express themselves.
So I want to start
with a story of one
of those millions
of young people,
just to give a sense of
what the experience is
like for young people when they
join this Scratch community.
So this is the story about
a young person-- everyone
starts with a user name.
This is someone whose
username was Ipzy.
And Ipzy described-- you know,
when Ipzy was growing up,
one of their favorite
things to do was drawing.
They loved to draw things.
And Ipzy got
started with Scratch
when one of Ipzy's
friends explained
that Scratch was a way to
make her drawings come alive.
And that was really
intriguing for Ipzy.
So Ipzy tried out, Scratch.
And this is one of
the first projects
that they worked on in Scratch.
And what I like about
this is you can see
it's Ipzy's drawing, and there's
just a little bit of animation.
You see the ears are wiggling
and the eyes are moving.
And you can almost see here
Ipzy starting with something
that they're comfortable
with, and like dipping
their toe in the water
to try something new.
So this is the
Scratch programming.
For those who haven't
seen it, with Scratch,
you build up programs
by stacking together
graphical programming blocks.
This is one of Ipzy's
first programs and project,
as a way to start exploring
to testing something new.
And Ipzy found that
they really enjoyed
working on these
types of projects,
so they started spending
more time on Scratch.
A little while later,
this is a project
that really got Ipzy
known in the community.
You can see Ipzy's projects got
more and more sophisticated.
This is a project that Ipzy
worked on called Lemonade Time.
And in this project, you
can use the arrow keys
to move the otter.
And as the otter moves
around, the otter
gets tips from different
animals that the otter comes
across-- the bird, the frog.
And the goal is to be able to
get all the ingredients to make
lemonade.
So you have to
get the ideas, you
have get instructions
and tips, on where
to get the water, the lemons,
the sugar to make lemonade.
So Ipzy put this in
the online community
and it became really popular.
So if you go to the
online community,
you can still see this.
This is the page
for Lemonade Time.
And you can see it was
viewed 17,000 times.
It was loved close
to 2,000 times.
It was remixed 88 times.
Because in Scratch,
anybody can take a project
and then make modifications
to it, changing the images,
changing the code.
It's all sort of an open
source culture around Scratch.
Everything that is shared is
covered by Creative Commons.
So as long as you
give credit, you
can remix other
people's projects.
So 88 people made remixed
projects of Lemonade Time.
Nearly 2,000 people--
1,830 people--
gave comments,
giving suggestions
or feedback or encouragement.
And you can tell that Ipzy was
listening to these comments
and reading them
carefully, because if you
look in the instructions
here, it says, "edit--
due to popular demand, the otter
walks a little faster now."
So like any good
designer, Ipzy's
listening to the audience
and making changes,
based on what comes across.
A lot of the comments
we're about Ipzy's artwork.
People really liked
Ipzy's artwork.
And several people
said, we'd love
to see more of your artwork.
Can you share more
of your artwork?
So Ipzy started putting up some
projects like this one, branded
as Ipzy Studio.
And it's a collection
of different artwork
that Ipzy's sharing with
the rest the community.
And Ipzy wrote, "You can edit
them as much as you want,
but you must credit me if you
use any of these sprites."
Sprites are the
objects in Scratch.
And this is a sign
that Ipzy was learning
how to be a good member
of the online community,
and sort of understanding
this idea of sharing
under Creative Commons.
And this was definitely
an evolution for Ipzy,
as it is for many
members of the community.
At first, Ipzy was
upset when people
were taking their projects and
remixing them or using them
in different ways, or
taking characters, feeling
like, that's my character, they
shouldn't be able to do it.
But over time, Ipzy
came to recognize that,
when everyone shares,
everyone benefits.
At this end, our team, we
were in constant communication
with people in the
community, trying
to help people understand this.
But it's a constant--
sometimes, we always say,
learning how to share
is even more difficult
than learning how to code.
So that's the real thing
that I think a lot of kids
are learning.
But you know, Ipzy
was doing this,
but then, as they
continued to do it,
they came up with all
sorts of different things.
Here was even a
tutorial that Ipzy
did showing how to make
scrolling backgrounds.
You saw in the Lemonade
Time, that the background
was scrolling behind
the otter character,
as you moved the otter.
It's not so easy to make
scrolling backgrounds
in Scratch.
We're trying to figure
out how to make it easier,
but it's not so easy.
But Ipzy figured
out how to do it,
and they made this tutorial
showing how to do it,
and then even commented the code
showing people how to do it.
This, again, suddenly
took us by surprise.
When we imagined that
we would do tutorials,
and some teachers
would do tutorials,
what took us by surprise
is that so many kids
wanted to do tutorials.
So if you go to the
Scratch website,
there are thousands
and thousands
of tutorials done by
kids-- how to do scrolling,
you know, how to use variables,
how to use the vector paint
editor, how to make your
projects popular on Scratch.
People do tutorials
about everything.
So we found that just people
are using the community
in so many different ways.
So I think, just by
looking at these projects,
you can see what Ipzy is
taking away from participating
in the community.
And I think what we see is
Ipzy is really developing
as a creative thinker.
And we think that's more
important today than ever
before.
For us, it's not just about
learning the coding skills,
although, clearly, if you
look at the scrolling back,
Ipzy's clearly doing
learning some coding skills.
But for us, what's
most important
is that Ipzy's really
learning to think creatively.
And I think that's more
important today than ever
before.
You know, we live
in a world that's
changing so quickly that we
don't know exactly what skills
kids will need in the
future as they grow up,
but we know they're going to
need to be able to come up
with creative solutions to
the unexpected things they
confront.
Because they will be
confronting all sorts
of unexpected and
new situations.
And we think that's
what's happening
with young people like Ipzy.
So to try to support
that development
of creative thinking,
we developed Scratch
with four guiding principles.
We called them the four P's of
creative learning-- project,
passion, peers, and play.
So with everything
we do, whether it's
developing Scratch,
or running a workshop,
or giving advice to
parents about what toys
to get for their
kids, we're always
guided by thinking about
these four P's, because it's
a good framework for thinking
about how you can really
help support creative thinking.
So if you look at
Scratch, you can
see that it really is aligned
and guided by these four P's
of creative learning.
The first one-- projects.
Well, you saw Ipzy was just
constantly making projects,
and the Scratch website
is based on projects.
It's the core unit of
sharing on Scratch.
There's 30 million projects
that kids have shared.
Now, it might seem
obvious, if you
look at Scratch, you
say, well, of course,
they're working on projects.
But that's not the way
most kids learn to code.
Go to most coding
websites and kids
are given a puzzle or
a problem to solve.
They get the answer.
And then they're moved on
to a next puzzle or problem.
And again, when I
was 10 years old,
I would have enjoyed doing that.
A lot of kids enjoy doing it.
And you can learn some
computational concepts
that way.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But if you really want to
develop as a creative thinker,
it's not just a
matter of learning
how to solve a certain puzzle,
but being able to do a project.
And with a project, I mean,
to start with your own idea,
to develop some prototype
with it, to show it to others,
to experiment with it, to get
feedback, to keep revising it,
to have a way of expressing
your ideas to the world.
So with a project,
kids, they aren't just
developing their thinking, but
also developing their voice,
coming up with an idea
and expressing their ideas
to the world.
So we really try to see Scratch
as it's like a type of writing.
The same way when
you learn to write,
it's not just to get
tasks done, but it's
a way of expressing your ideas.
We see Scratch the same way,
as kids work on projects.
And this second P of
passion, I think we all
know that we're all willing
to work longer and harder
and persist in the
face of challenges,
where we're working on something
we really care deeply about.
So for us, it's so
important to give kids
the opportunity to work on
things they really care about.
So as we were
developing Scratch,
we wanted to make sure that you
could do many different things
with it.
Because we know
that different kids
have different interests
and different passions,
and we wanted to
make sure to align
with the interests of
all different kids.
I mean, some people
suggested, well,
why don't you do it so all
you do is to make games?
Kids like games.
And it's true, a lot
of kids like games.
But about kids who
don't like games?
Then they wouldn't
be interested in it.
We wanted to make sure
that kids could make games,
but they can also make
animations and simulations
and interactive stories.
Because different kids
have different interests,
we wanted to let all
kids build on things
they really want to do.
And you can see that in Ipzy's
case, where Ipzy was building
upon their interest in
drawing, and used that as a way
to get into coding.
With peers, we saw
from the beginning
that we really wanted to make
sure that learning to code
was a social experience,
that too often,
when people think
of coding, they
think of the individual
sitting by themselves
looking at the screen.
And of course, you spend some
time doing that and, you know,
sometimes that's an important
part of the process.
But we know that
a lot of learning
happens in collaboration
with others.
So when we launched Scratch, we
launched the online community
at the same time, integrated
with the programming language.
And to us, that was
really important.
And a lot of people,
they weren't quite sure
what we were doing,
because why do
you have to have an online
computer with a programming
language?
But for us, the online community
both served as a source of--
it was a way to have an
audience for what you'd created.
Because when you
create something,
you want to be able to
share ideas with others
and get feedback, because we
saw Ipzy getting feedback.
It also serves as a
source of inspiration.
You can look at the
online community,
and you see, again, millions of
projects that gives you ideas
of what you want to create.
So we wanted to have
a way that would have
kids connect with each other.
They would learn
with and from one
another, both to get feedback
and inspiration from one
another.
And then, finally, play, and
I sometimes call play the most
misunderstood of the P's.
Because people here play
and they just think,
oh, it's about laughing
and having fun.
And there's nothing wrong
with laughing and having fun.
But we think of play
in a different way.
We see it almost as an attitude,
or an approach, to the things
you're doing.
When you have a
playful approach,
it means you're willing to
take risks, to try new things,
to test the boundaries,
to experiment.
And we wanted to make
sure that was possible.
So we've really set up Scratch
so it's easy to put things
together, take them apart.
You can make your
programs sort of
like building with LEGO bricks.
LEGO bricks are so tinkerable,
and you can play with them,
try new things, take it
apart, try something else,
continually iterate.
And we wanted to make Scratch
really easy to iterate so you
could keep experimenting.
So that's what we did,
and tried to make it--
and we also, in
moderating the committee,
to make sure the community
is a type of place
where you feel safe
experimenting and trying
new things.
So these four P's have guided
the things that we're doing.
And from this, I
think this really
underlies why Scratch has been
growing over the last 10 years.
And it really has grown beyond
what we would have imagined.
So last year, there were
200 million unique visitors
to Scratch.
Now, not all of them
were creating projects.
About 10%, about 20 million
people created projects.
But people just
visiting and trying out
Scratch and its things,
there's about 200 million
unique visitors.
You know, every
country in the world.
From the beginning,
we wanted to translate
to many different
languages, so it's
easy to make the blocks switch
to whatever language you want.
And even if you see
someone else's project--
a project that was
done in New York--
a child in Tokyo could look
at it and switch the blocks
to Japanese, make a change to
it, and a child in Buenos Aires
could then change the
blocks to Spanish.
So it facilitates collaboration
by everyone changing it
to their own language.
45% female, 100%--
everything is free.
The software is free,
the community is free.
It's also open source.
So we've really
tried to build it
where all of that development
is done in an open source way.
And we have people helping out.
We've been really appreciative.
A bunch of people of
Google have helped out.
We did an initiative last
year through Google Serve
and people helped out.
We hope, as we
continue to develop,
we'll have others
helping us out.
And every day, there's
150,000 new projects
that kids are creating
in the Scratch community.
Who's creating them?
This is a histogram of
the ages that people
joined the community.
The peak is at age 12.
And this pretty much hits
what we had aimed for.
When we developed Scratch,
we aimed at age 8 to 16,
and that's roughly where
the bulk of the people are.
After Scratch came out,
we did another version
called ScratchJr, which is for
ages 5 to 7 at the lower end.
One thing that
took us by surprise
is there's more use at the
higher end than we imagined.
Because even though we
designed it for 8 to 16,
it's getting used in a growing
number of introductory computer
science courses at universities,
sometimes for a whole semester,
sometimes just to get started.
Like, at Harvard, they
use it as the first week
of the introductory computer
science course there--
CS50.
And they found that,
when they shifted over
to doing Scratch
in the beginning,
the number of people
dropping the course
went down dramatically,
especially among women.
They used to have huge
dropout rates of women.
And at least, they speculate
that, with Scratch, people
were able to have
success very quickly,
and get a sense of
what's possible,
and what type of things
they might do with Scratch.
And then, after
it, in that course,
they do shift to other
things, but Scratch
serves as a foundation for
getting people started.
Within the use of Scratch,
when it started 10 years ago,
a lot of it was being used in
homes and after school centers.
Right now, the fastest
growth is in schools.
There's a lot of--
you know, and that's partly
it's a cultural phenomenon
that more schools are getting
interested in introducing
coding.
So Scratch is being used
in many different schools.
Here in New York, it's one of
the languages that's really
being used, especially
in elementary schools,
with the different
efforts and CS4--
all efforts-- really
supporting the use of Scratch
going out into schools.
I wanted to give you
some sense of how
it's being used in
schools, so I'll
show a few examples
of things that we've
seen in different schools.
The first one is from India.
This one is from Bangalore,
where this was a--
I think it was a 13-year-old.
It was in the science class,
where they were studying
the layers of the earth.
So as their final project, they
were making a Scratch project
about what they learned,
to share what they learned,
about the layers of the earth.
So the teacher explained
to us that this
dude-- he's speaking his
native language of Kannada,
and he's explaining the
different layers of the earth.
And what he was
really excited about
was the fact that things
are moving inside the earth.
So he's explaining
things are moving.
And you can see, he gets
down to the water table where
things are moving and puts in
sound effects for the water
table.
So it's, again,
a way of sharing.
So this was a case where
Scratch was actually
introduced at school and
everyone was using it.
Sometimes kids learn Scratch at
home, but bring it into school.
That's the next example.
This is from a middle
school in the United States,
where they were studying, in
a social studies class, Rapa
Nui, or Easter Island.
The island's off
of South America.
And this student did something
sort of like "SimCity,"
but Sim Rapa Nui.
He had learned about the
economy and the culture.
And you know, fishing is
important to the economy,
so to survive there,
you have to cut down
a branch to make a fishing
rod and go fishing.
But if you take down
too many branches,
happiness goes down, because
there's a certain way that they
respect the environment.
So it was a way for him to
show what he had learned,
but also to help other
people learn about Rapa Nui.
I'll show one more example
from an elementary school.
And this is an elementary
school, where--
I really like these
examples-- where it's
used across the curriculum.
So this elementary
school teacher
introduces Scratch
and, in the same way
that if you learn
about-- you learn
how to write, you use writing
in all of your classes,
whether it's history
or science, you
use your writing everywhere--
they used Scratch everywhere.
This is an example
from a book report.
When they read
"Charlotte's Web,"
this was one of the
students book reports.
And you can see,
they're using language.
They'd read the book and
they're writing about the book.
But one thing that caught my
attention with this example
is notice how the
pig gets smaller
as it goes further away.
So this was also using what
they learned in art class
about perspective, that to make
something look further away,
you make it smaller.
But then, if you
look at the code,
in order to make it smaller,
what this student had to do
was multiply it by a fraction--
multiply the size by a
fraction-- less than 1
repeatedly to make it smaller
and smaller and smaller.
So he was learning mathematical
ideas while doing that.
But again, using mathematical
ideas with a purpose.
So there was a reason, you know?
They knew why they were
multiplying fractions.
Most kids, you're taught
multiplying fractions
and you think, why
am I learning this?
But here, they were learning
multiplying fractions
for a purpose.
There was a reason
for doing it, and they
could make good use of it here.
Actually, right before this
talk, I was talking to Max.
I was very happy he came.
He was telling me about,
in his third grade,
they were making
games where they
had to show some things
about rocks and minerals,
so that other people
learn something
they didn't know before
about rocks and minerals.
So I think that's
another great example.
I think it was just
recently he was doing that.
And that's a way
of sort of using
Scratch as a way of
communicating and sharing
with one another.
So I think we see more and
more of that happening.
So in our collaboration
with Google,
we also are doing a lot
aiming at schools-- you know,
with Google CS First program.
It's an after school
initiative, but increasingly
being focused on in school.
So we see that as a
great collaboration.
And we're really pleased
that, as CS First got started,
they chose Scratch as the
primary programming language.
So we've worked with them, and
it's been great to see the way
that they have built all sorts
of resources around Scratch.
So those types of collaborations
are really important for us,
because we have a
relatively small team.
We have the language out
there, but the CS First team
has done a great job of
creating all sorts of resources
around it and supporting both
the mentors and facilitators
running these sessions,
and also developing
the materials for
kids to use as well.
So we're really look
forward to doing that.
Let me give one more extended
example of one where--
and we see this
happening a lot, where--
of someone who starts to learn
Scratch in school, but then
continues doing things
outside of school.
And that also makes
us really happy.
Actually, I was at an event
in New York City-- actually,
it was during CS Ed Week in
December, I was down here.
And the CSforALL people had
an event that I went to.
And there, I met a couple
of high school students.
And I was talking to them.
And they weren't
using Scratch anymore.
They'd used it in elementary
and middle school.
But what I really liked is
they said what they liked
about Scratch was, they
said, it was the one thing
they did at school they wanted
to continue to do on their own
after school.
And for us, I think
everything should be that way.
So everything we develop,
we try to make it
that kids would want
to do on their own.
And that was the case-- so this
is another member the scratch
community.
bubble103 is her user name.
She's from South Africa.
And she first learned
about Scratch in school,
where this is one
of the projects--
if you go to the profile,
you can see the water cycle
and it shows how the water
from the lake or the ocean
goes up and makes a cloud,
and then it goes and it rains.
So it's talking about
the water cycle.
But as she learned
that, she then
started making games on her own.
There's a fabulous farming
game that she made.
She made a presentation
about South Africa.
She was really proud
of South Africa.
And she wanted to share
her pride with other people
in the community.
And she also made
tutorials, like Ipzy did.
And bubble103 had
used variables,
and she was excited about what
she could do with variables
and wanted to share
that with others.
But the project that really
caught our attention,
and a lot of people's
attention, was a project
that she worked on
called Colour Divide.
And this is a
collaborative project
that she did with five
or six other scratchers.
They were like in three
or four other countries.
So they started exchanging
ideas in the online community.
And bubble103 had started this
role playing game with others,
and then decided to make
a trailer for a movie
that they wanted to make
about Colour Divide.
So I'll show you now like a
one minute clip, this trailer
that they did.
And this is, again, five
different scratchers
working together to put
together the trailer for "Colour
Divide."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Welcome to Aurora,
land of colour and magic.
Every child at the age of 12
faces the Test to determine
their magical strength
and their colour rank.
But all is not as it seems.
- This test means
everything to me.
I can't fail.
- What if I don't get a colour?
- I don't want to
colour anyways.
I'm going to fail the test.
- But banishment.
- Haven't you ever
wondered what's out there?
I mean, there's got
to be something.
I got too close
to the gates once,
and I saw something-- a boy.
I hate living in this place.
The magicians are dictators.
They tore my family apart.
They destroyed-- they destroyed
my home and burned my mother.
- Together-- we'll fail
this test together.
- Let's see what you're
made of then, shall we?
[END PLAYBACK]
MITCHEL RESNICK: I think one
thing that really struck us
with this is the fact--
obviously, it was a
big programming effort.
They spent a lot
of time doing this.
But you can really see
that, for bubble103, there
was sort of a deep
meaning behind this.
You know, talking about
growing up in South Africa,
talking about this colour
divide and everyone being given
a colour and being
ranked by your colour.
So we, then, talked
to her-- oops.
And she says, growing
up, I've definitely
seen the scars that
apartheid has left
on my country and the people.
I'm really exploring
that through
the different characters
that are part of this story.
And again, we see
this over and over.
A lot of the kids that
are using Scratch,
or oftentimes as they go
into their teen years,
they're exploring things about
their own identity, things
about the community around them.
So you see them
tackling issues that
are deeply important to them.
Of course, there's a
lot of things on Scratch
that are just funny animations.
But there also is an
opportunity for kids
to really develop their
own ideas, to share
ideas with others, and
use it as a way to sort
through important ideas.
And also, to sort through ways
of engaging with the design
process and the
creative process.
So bubble103 also said,
"Because of Scratch,
I've become more confident
to try new things
and express myself--
I'm more comfortable with taking
risks and making mistakes.
Now, when something
goes wrong, I
see it as an opportunity
to learn something new."
And again, that's what we
were hoping for with Scratch.
When I talked about the
importance of play, in my mind,
there's a playful approach,
a willingness to take risks,
a willingness to
have things go wrong,
and then an ability to try to
iterate and to debug things
when things go wrong,
and to try new things.
And that's exactly what she
was getting out of this.
So we're really happy when we
hear scratchers talk this way.
And bubble103 also talked
about the importance
of the online community for her.
She said, "I've been
constantly blown away
by the kind of support and
collaboration and sharing
that happens in the community.
That's one of the main things
that keeps me coming back
to Scratch every day."
And we see that over and
over, that, for a lot of kids,
they come to Scratch
to create a project.
They stay for the community.
They connect with
other people, the way
they share with each other.
In this case, collaborating
with others on projects,
interacting and getting
inspired by others.
And I think it's not an accident
that this example happens
to come from a young
woman in the community.
Just last night-- this
is my freshest data--
just last night, one of the
graduate students in our group,
Shruti Dhariwal,
was showing some
of the last data she was
looking at about some gender
differences on Scratch.
As I mentioned, it's about 45%
female, the Scratch population.
One thing we'd already
seen was that, if you
look at the number of
projects that people create,
the boys and girls
on Scratch each
create roughly the same
number of projects.
But Shruti was just looking at
the data and saw the following,
as far as on the
social side of Scratch,
where if you like a project,
you can give it a love.
And if you look on the
left hand side here,
you see that the female
participants on Scratch
are much more likely--
they give 50% more
loves than others.
So on average, each female
participant gives 12 loves.
Only 8 for male participants.
As far as giving comments
on other projects,
female participants,
28; male, 16--
almost twice.
And for me, I found
this really striking
because we'd already seen,
in looking at the community,
that getting social
feedback on the community
is the most
important determinant
about whether someone
stays on Scratch.
So when someone puts up
a project on Scratch,
how quickly they receive
some social feedback--
a comment or a love--
has a huge influence on whether
they make a second project.
So the fact that the
young women on Scratch
are doing much more
commenting and loving really
shows the important role
they're playing to help continue
people working on Scratch.
And it really shows how the
creative side and the community
side of Scratch really
are tightly linked
with one another.
So this is something that
we continue to look at.
And I think, right now, we're
sitting on top this huge trove
of data, because there's 30
million projects on Scratch,
and we've saved everything.
So we're still
sorting through it
to try to learn more
about the creative process
and the coding process, as we
sort through this on Scratch.
I wanted to end by giving
some examples looking ahead,
about the next generation of
Scratch that we're working on.
So we're now working
on a third generation
of Scratch called Scratch 3.0
that will launch this August.
The first generation of
Scratch that came out in 2007
was a downloadable application
that you used locally.
And then, you could
share on the website,
where the community was.
If you saw something
in the community that
looked interesting, you had
to download it to see the code
and play with the code.
The second generation
of Scratch, in 2013,
was all in the browser.
So you could start
authoring in the browser.
And that really led to a
real growth in Scratch.
It really removed a
lot of the friction
between creating and sharing.
So you could sort of see
things in the community,
go inside right away,
right online see the code,
manipulate the code,
try different things.
So it really opened
up and really lead
to some of the recent
growth in Scratch.
The third generation
we're coming out now,
one of the motivations for
it is to make it much better
suited for mobile.
You know, back in
around 2010 or so,
as we started working
on Scratch 2.0,
we made the decision
to implement it
in Flash, which, at the time,
seemed like a good decision.
Right now, that is
not looking so good,
so we really need to be moving
into a new infrastructure.
So Scratch 3.0 will
be all HTML5-based.
It will be much more
designed with mobile in mind.
So that's one thing
that we wanted to do,
and we sort of need to do.
But we also wanted
to make it much more
of a basic platform
that can be extended
in all sorts of different ways.
And this is something, again,
we've done a lot collaboration
with Google.
For the programming
language itself,
we've been working
with the Blockly team,
and building on the
infrastructure of Blockly
from here.
But then, using some
of the design ideas
we've had from Scratch, we've
had the great collaboration
of working together on
the new set of blocks
that we were using for this.
And these blocks,
again, are open source,
as Blockly has been.
So in addition to using these
blocks in our Scratch 3.0,
we want to have this
as a standard grammar
for a block-based
programming that anybody
can embed in their
own apps or toys
or whatever products they have.
So we're trying to make this
sort of a standard programming
grammar for everybody.
But then, we'll also use
it inside our own version
of Scratch 3.0.
Another way in which we're
extending Scratch and making
it more modular is making it
much easier to extend Scratch.
So in addition to the core
capabilities of Scratch,
we're having a whole, what
we call, the extension
mechanism to make
it easy for people
to add new Scratch blocks.
So of course, we want to have it
so that we can extend Scratch,
but we also want to let
everybody else extend Scratch
as well.
So now, this is
not necessarily--
most kids won't do this.
But this is more--
developers can add their
own Scratch blocks.
And there's a way down
here, just in the interface,
if you just want to
add an extension,
you can go down to the bottom
left corner, add an extension.
Let me give you some
examples of how to do it.
So I'm actually going to
run some things live here
from the prototype
of Scratch 3.0.
Sorry, there it is.
So this is using the
extension with the micro:bit.
A lot of you are probably
familiar with the micro:bit.
They're a very low
cost interface device.
So here's the board.
It's very-- the BBC
helped in developing this,
so they've given it to every
school child in England.
It's now spread into
the United States.
It only costs like less
than $20 to get the board.
And what we're doing now is-- so
we can do something like this.
[BELLS RINGING]
I know this is a--
so here, it's using these
extra blocks as just saying,
this has an accelerometer,
so when it's tilted--
[BELLS RINGING]
--it's supposed make
the flowers spin,
and then it should have a little
smiley face show up on here.
So you can see the code there.
So again, we just want to
make it easy for anybody.
So again, we worked
with the micro:bit team,
but we wanted to let anybody who
is making new types of hardware
be able to extend it.
So we're working with
the LEGO company,
so as they add
new robotics kits,
they'll be using Scratch and
just having extensions to--
they'll both use the Scratch
blocks in their own apps,
but also will have
extensions in the Scratch
3.0, where you can control
your LEGO robotics.
We're also working on some of
our own hardware extensions.
So this is one.
Right now, we're calling
it the Scratch Bit.
It's in development.
One of the graduate students
in the group, Kreg Hanning,
is working with others,
including Andrew Sliwinski,
who's leading the whole
Scratch 3.0 development
process, and a bunch
of other people
on developing the Scratch Bit.
So here-- actually, I'm going
to put this full screen.
So hopefully if I--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this also has
an accelerometer.
And I'm trying to get the
balloons and the tacos.
And I get different points.
I get two points for
every taco and one point
for every balloon.
And if want things
get out of the way--
I think if I cover--
I thought there was a horn that
sounds, but maybe that's not--
[HORN SOUNDING]
There it is.
But the idea is trying to
make it so that it's very easy
to take different types of
physical devices like this,
and with different sensors--
accelerometers, light sensors,
whatever, you know,
buttons, knobs--
and be able to
wirelessly communicate.
These are all Bluetooth
communication.
In addition to extending
it through hardware,
we're going to extend
things either to a web based
or software side.
Here's an example that's
already in Scratch,
because of the spirit of the
type of things we're doing.
This is one that
uses the camera.
And notice--
[SPLASHING SOUNDS]
Whoops.
It should be using the camera.
It's not.
AUDIENCE: Hit I, I think.
MITCHEL RESNICK: Oh,
did I hit the wrong one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MITCHEL RESNICK: Let me try
it one more time and see if--
Thank you.
So here, you see the
minifigs are falling, but--
[BOUNCY SOUND]
[LAUGHTER]
[BOUNCY SOUNDS]
Or I can do it with my head.
And you know, I think
a big part of what
we end up doing in our group--
if we see inside,
we can take a look.
And this is the key block.
You have very few new blocks.
This one just says, if there's
video motion on this sprite,
and it's grabbed by the
threshold, then do something.
So obviously, there's a
huge amount of information
coming from the camera.
I think a big thing
about what we do
is how can we take
all that information,
put it into the right
building blocks,
to let kids use it
in a meaningful way.
So we just did it, so you
see how much motion there
is on your sprite.
In this case, if the
minifig is falling,
it sees motion in
the background,
it then jumps upwards.
We also have it that you can
see what direction it is.
So you could also do it,
if I swat in one direction,
it can move one way
or the other way.
But just a few simple
primitives is what we're doing.
We're also, in 3.0, extending
this to do some things
with object detection.
Let me show one other
thing that we're doing.
This is one that actually just
got added to the prototype
this week.
This is one of the
ones that we're
working with people at Google
on that has a translate feature.
So these are just
some of the extensions
that we're working on now.
Some Division 1 is what
I was just talking about.
Here's a translate one.
And notice there's a new block.
Let me make it bigger.
So basically, you can translate
a word to any language,
or you could just have
it translate whatever
the web browser is set to.
So I can make this, and
then it would translate
things to whatever the person
using the project, whatever
their browser is set to.
But if I just set it to
a particular language,
so I could just, say, to French.
So if I translate French
hello, it says bonjour.
I can then put it inside a say
block to have the cat say--
so normally-- oops.
So there's the cat saying hello.
But now, if I just
say, translate hello
to French for two seconds,
now the cat will say, bonjour.
And if instead of
saying to French,
I say, translate hello to
wherever the browser is
set to, well, then, the cat
will talk in whatever language
the browser is set to.
So these are things we're doing.
So again, this is
a great thing that
came out of the collaboration.
I'll show one more
sort of a fake example,
because this isn't actually
running in the prototype.
So it's a little bit of
a trick, just to show you
what we're aiming for.
Again, we're working with Google
on speech recognition blocks.
We know that obviously
communicating with speech
is something that kids are
interacting with all the time
now.
But for us, it's
really important
that kids don't just spend
their time feeling it's magical,
talking to something and
then it talks back to you.
We want kids to feel that they
can create things this way.
So we want kids to be able
to create their own speech
interfaces.
So we're having some new blocks
on the speech synthesis side,
where you'll actually
say the words out
loud with this
synthesized voice,
but also do some
speech recognition.
So like here's one where, if you
see the key part here, it says,
when I hear what time is
it, it will then speak,
it's party time.
And then, it'll play
a certain sound.
So I say, what time is it?
SYNTHESIZED VOICE (ON
COMPUTER): It's party time.
[PARTY MUSIC PLAYING]
MITCHEL RESNICK: So
again, our real hope
is that it will let kids
create their own type of speech
interfaces and conversational
interfaces with these blocks.
And again, we're still
trying to figure out
the exact right building blocks.
Because I think the key
thing is making sure
that we preserve what's
the core power of it,
but make it simple enough
and versatile enough
that kids are going
to be able to use it
in many different ways.
So just to wrap up, you
know, we see lots of ways
that Scratch is
going to continue
to get out to the world.
And for us, we do want to see
it is a new type of fluency.
It's something that, when
we teach kids to write,
it's not just so that they
can use writing in their jobs,
although people do use
writing in their jobs,
but so that they can express
their ideas to the world.
And we see Scratch the same way.
We want to let all
kids grow up feeling
they can use the powerful
technology of their times
in a way that they can
express their voice,
express their
ideas, to the world.
And to do that, we want to
keep on that focus of projects,
passion, peers, and play.
Because there's always going
to be new technologies,
whether it's object
recognition, speech recognition,
speech synthesis.
We want to keep integrating
new technologies,
but always in this
framework of providing kids
with creative
learning experiences
and leaving them in control,
so that it's not they're just
interacting with things, but
things where they can do it.
Because I think that's going
to be the key to help kids
grow up to become full
and active contributors
in tomorrow's society.
If you want to read
more about this,
I did just finish a book that is
called "Lifelong Kindergarten."
We use the metaphor
of kindergarten,
because I've been really
inspired by the way kids
learn in kindergarten.
The idea of the four P's
came from observing kids
in kindergarten.
If you think of the
classic kindergarten,
that kids are building towers
with blocks, making pictures
with finger paints and crayons.
In the process, they
learn important ideas.
They build a tower, they learn
about structure stability.
But even more
important, they learn
about the creative process.
You know, they learn how
to put things together,
to experiment, to iterate.
Too often, when they
leave kindergarten,
they end up sitting in
desks, listening to lectures,
filling out worksheets.
And that doesn't provide
them with the opportunity
to continue to develop
as creative thinkers.
So they really aren't
getting prepared for what's
needed in today's society.
And to make matters worse, you
know, a lot of kindergartens
today, you go in there and kids
are drilling on math flashcards
and doing phonics worksheets.
Kindergarten is becoming
more like the rest of school.
And what we want to do, and
what I talk about in the book,
is to make the rest of
school, the rest of life, more
like kindergarten.
And that really inspired
us with Scratch.
So from kindergarten, we got the
four P's that inspired Scratch.
So the book tells you more
about the underlying ideas
for Scratch, to do it.
I may just end with
one final thing.
Every year, we do
have an annual dinner
in New York City that's
organized by the Scratch
Foundation.
Lisa O'Brien's here,
the executive director
of the Scratch Foundation
that helps support Scratch.
And this year-- we honor
two people each year--
and this year, one of the
two people we're honoring
is Maggie Johnson from
Google, the great way
that she serves as a champion
for so many of these causes.
So it's been great collaborating
with Maggie and others
at Google, and we have
such admiration and respect
for what she's doing.
So we're honoring Maggie,
along with David Siegel,
who's been a great partner.
He leads a company here called
Two Sigma that is, again,
a great champion for
supporting kids and coding
and creative thinking.
But thank you very much.
I'd be happy to take
some questions now.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Thanks so much for
the presentation.
Very exciting.
I was wondering
if you can clarify
the associations between
Scratch, Blockly, and Code.org,
or any other associations
we may have heard about,
but are a little
confusing, at least to me.
MITCHEL RESNICK: Yeah.
So here's-- I'll give a
little bit of history.
So Scratch got
started around 2007.
And there were some other
people, based on Scratch,
that started working on other
blocks related languages.
And in fact, some of the other
things that got done then
inspired Blockly.
Another MIT professor,
named Hal Abelson,
spent a sabbatical at Google,
worked with others at Google,
and started the Blockly project.
Or at least he started
App Inventor, which
was making use of Blockly.
So it's sort of
using together some
of these same block-based
programming ideas.
But Blockly was being developed
separately from Scratch.
But it was in the same spirit.
As we started working on Scratch
3.0, we decided to join forces,
because we saw that
each of us could
gain from working together.
We had lots of experience of
how to make these blocks really
work well with kids, so we had
a lot more experience working
with kids, where the Blockly
group had a great experience,
and great expertise, in
making a great infrastructure
for these blocks-based
languages.
So we saw what each
of us had to gain
from working with one another.
So we've joined forces.
So basically, our new
version of Scratch blocks
is building on top of Blockly.
So our Scratch that we're using
are now on top of Blockly.
It's a fork off a Blockly.
Blockly continues
to be developed,
and we're sort of
building on top of that
and making it specialized
especially for kids.
Code.org, which is a
separate organization,
has a separate site, is
focused on getting kids engaged
with coding and CS Education.
They have used Blockly in
a lot of their activities.
So they've put a
lot of activities
online of their own, some
of which used Blockly.
So Blockly gets used
by many other sites.
Code.org also features many
other types of activities
by others.
So our work with
Scratch sometimes
will get featured on
the Code.org site.
So Code.org is sort of
this general site that
has their own activities,
some of them based on Blockly,
but also they feature,
especially at CS Ed Week
other coding activities.
Hopefully, that gave some sense.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks a lot for being here.
My previous job,
before I was here,
was as a K-12 math
and coding teacher.
And I used Scratch
in the classroom,
but this was right
around when 2.0 came out,
before you had a lot of the
classroom management tools
that I think you've had
in the past few years.
And I'm just curious, as Scratch
moves into a lot of classrooms,
as you noted, with CS4
and other programs,
I'm curious how you
feel about-- like,
you mentioned the
projects on the one hand,
and sort of the flash
cards and the drilling
on the other hand--
like, how do you
feel about Scratch
being sort of molded
to fit into a mandatory
classroom environment, where
people are interested in
defined learning metrics,
seeing progress, assessments,
and things like that?
MITCHEL RESNICK: Yeah.
That's a good question.
And I mean, I do think we want
to make sure that, as Scratch
moves into schools, that what
we love most about Scratch
doesn't get squeezed out of it.
And I think there are
ways of doing that.
But I think we are constantly
working on, and working
with educators, to feel what
are the best ways of introducing
Scratch into classrooms
and maintaining
the spirit of Scratch.
One of my former
students, who's now
a professor at Harvard Graduate
School of Education, Karen
Brennan, has done a
great job of this.
She's made a curriculum
called the Creative Computing
Curriculum Guide.
It's based on Scratch,
but it is very--
it's shown how to make use
of it in classroom settings.
So that's one example of trying
to take this Scratch program
language, but
introduced in a way
that we feel stays
true to the values,
but still is aligned with
the needs of classrooms.
So there are many--
others work on that as well.
So I think Scratch,
and other languages,
are getting introduced
in many different ways.
Our hope is to try to
make sure that it gets out
to the world in a way that
stays true to those values.
But there are tensions there.
I think some of the tensions
come about because the things
that we care about most--
I talked earlier
about the importance
of helping kids learn
to think creatively--
it's not easy to get a
quantitative measure of how
you've advanced in
your creative thinking.
It's much easier to get
a quantitative measure
of how often do you use
conditional statements.
So you can look at
someone's projects
and see they're using
conditionals more,
and grade them based on that.
We hope that that's not the way
kids end up being evaluated,
because that'll sort
of distort, we think,
what is going to
be most important.
They'll be learning
something that way.
It's not saying that
there's no value in that.
But I think we want to make
sure that kids continue
to have this learning, not
just the core computational
concepts, but also
design strategies
and creative ways of thinking.
So we're constantly
working with educators
trying to feel the
best way of doing that.
It's an ongoing process.
I think a lot of people are
continuing to work on it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question about the
design of the Scratch language.
I think, in a lot of
other languages, some
of those complicated
things that you
were talking about, like playing
audio, might be part of an SDK,
or a standard
library, or something.
Whereas, in Scratch,
maybe those are
more like keywords
or blocks that
are built into the language.
So I was just wondering
what you thought about that?
MITCHEL RESNICK: Yeah.
Well, we wanted to--
as we started Scratch,
we wanted to have
a relatively-- we
wanted to make it
easy for everyone
to have sort of of this
consistent collection that
was going to be used.
And we worried that there are
too many different things.
If you have to go and
search for different things,
it was going to make it
more challenging for people
to get started.
So we tried to
figure out what were
the core things we felt
was most important,
and there's 100 or so
core blocks in Scratch.
And we tried to think,
what are the things that
are going to be most important
for the way kids want
to express themselves.
Before we started
Scratch, Tammy had
mentioned we had developed
these network of after school
centers called Computer
Clubhouses for young people
in low income communities.
And we saw that kids
at these clubhouses,
they wanted to create their own
interactive stories and games,
and they loved
manipulating media.
But there weren't
good tools to let
them create their interactive
stories and games.
So we definitely
had them in mind.
So we wanted to make sure
they were the right primitive
building blocks to let you
manipulate sound, music,
images, you know, photos.
Make it easy to bring in your
own and also to personalize it,
to bring in your own voice,
to bring in your own songs,
bring your own images.
So we put a priority on that to
making our core set of things.
And we found you could
go pretty far with that.
As you can see now, we are
having these extensions.
We're trying to see how we
can keep with that core set,
but still make it possible
to extend in different ways.
There's still challenges
that we have to think about.
By having an online
community, that's
one reason we wanted
to keep it consistent.
So if you saw something
on the online community,
it was clear that you had
all the tools to make it.
So now, if you see something
on the online community
that's using the micro:bit, but
you don't have the micro:bit,
what does that mean?
Is it confusing?
So we're trying to figure how
to keep the community done
in a way that you
could filter out things
that aren't relevant for you.
So those are still things that
we're trying to work through.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned that you've
worked a little bit
with LEGO and Scratch,
and I was wondering
if you guys were
working on kind of bringing
Scratch to MINDSTORMS?
And you know, if you've
thought about the differences
between LEGO's approach to
a programming environment,
where it's all
image-based and you
have blocks that are just
pictures, and your approach,
where you have blocks that have
words on them, or like that?
MITCHEL RESNICK: Yeah.
And there's also some
other differences
in the program language
that comes with MINDSTORMS.
It also uses some different
programming paradigms as well.
It's just the
icons versus words.
It sort of grew out of a
dataflow tradition, rather than
a controlled flow tradition.
So there's some differences
in some of the ways
that the languages
are structured.
We continue work
closely with LEGO.
LEGO's working on the next
generation of MINDSTORMS.
We're working closely
with them and trying
to influence some of
the ways that they'll
be doing this in the future.
Obviously, we're
deeply committed
to the Scratch approach.
I do see that--
we're committed to the Scratch
approach of the basic grammar,
but for ScratchJr, we do use
icons, rather than words.
And we think, in some
situations, partly based on age
or partly on other
factors, we think
some of this using
the icons can be fine.
If people haven't
seen, on ScratchJr,
we use icons and
use it horizontally.
You snap blocks
together horizontally,
as opposed to vertically.
Because when you're using
icons, it makes more sense
doing it that way.
So we do see a place
for both word-based,
text-based on the blocks,
and icons on the blocks,
based on different situations.
So we're working together.
In fact, on Scratch
3.0, we're building it
all on the same
infrastructure, so it
will be easier to switch
back and forth between them.
And we think there's a role
for both, based on what age
you're aiming for, the
type of applications.
AUDIENCE: Can I just follow up?
Do you have an idea of what
that age switchover is between--
MITCHEL RESNICK: Yeah.
Well, what we chose for--
like, ScratchJr, we say 5 to 7,
Scratch is 8 and up.
But it's not that
they're hard boundaries.
We're also still exploring.
I think, on different devices,
as we do more things with
coding on mobile phones, we
think there might be some
advantage-- if you're doing
small programs on phones--
there might be some
advantages for all ages,
starting with icon-based
blocks, where you're just
doing small programs.
If you're doing longer programs,
going to text makes more sense.
So I think we're still
exploring some of the ways
to go between them.
It's not just age-based.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
I just want to be
respectful of people's time.
It's 1 o'clock now and I
think we're officially done.
But Mitchel, you're--
MITCHEL RESNICK:
Yeah, I'm happy to--
we could just maybe
call it an end,
but I'm happy to stay
around and people can just
come up and talk informally.
Maybe that makes sense?
TAMMY STERN: Sure.
MITCHEL RESNICK: OK.
TAMMY STERN: Thank you again.
[APPLAUSE]